michael smith of brother from another
right back here on the rich eisen show
to help us take him
and us to his show on nbc sports on
peacock how are you sir
good man what's going on with y'all well
i mean we're just hanging here it was
fun hanging with you and michael holly
on
on the brother from another peacock
first ever peacock nfl
playoff post game show that was fun
let's do it again chad
let's do it again absolutely that was a
lot of fun we got a divisional playoff
weekend coming up
as always uh but the hardened trade how
do you think that's going to work
how do you think it's going to work in
the in brooklyn you know what man i'm i
like to see things uh
from a positive perspective i like to
look at the glass half full okay i
actually think these dudes might over
correct
well first of all kyrie's got to show up
to work by the way
how many how many blockbuster trades
where nba teams have created the super
team that they feel is necessary to
defeat whoever they think they is need
defeating lebron and miami
uh or uh the the the right
right lebron in l.a however you want to
see how many of these trades have ever
started with well one of the stars
that's already there better show up
you know i mean very that's very uh
first 2021.
like listen i think as a nation we're
grieving nobody eventually last
wednesday and if he's really
you know that broken up that he needs to
be away
because of uh where we are as a country
right now i respect it
i respect it i think more of us should
take mental health sabbaticals it'd be
nice if he communicated his reasoning
with his uh organization is that what it
is michael is that really what it is
that the
the attack on the capital okay i'm just
wondering i have no idea this is what
i've read i have no idea haven't talked
to kyrie irving
and if it is that i'd love to hear and
say that not just to the team but to
everybody else sure
i love to hear i'd love to hear him
express that messaging
because we're at a time we're really
talking about uh mental health and
trauma in us in a more
enlightened sophisticated way to maybe
we ever have but we still have a long
way to go
and i think collectively when you
combine the pandemic
with our political strife i don't know
that we truly understand
uh you know the damage is being done to
us psychologically i'm not sure i'm not
i'm no philosopher don't get me wrong
but i just think it's a healthy
conversation they have we saw a lot of
that coming out of the bubble with
people like paul george
tell the conversation have about mental
health right now and if kyrie needs a
break
for whatever reason i mean we do low
maintenance for people's knees and
ankles
right hacking right do low you need low
maintenance for your brain too
i was saying that before michael is that
in our day and age for sure
that if an athlete uh if he or she
have a crutch like a physical crutch
or have a cast we can understand it
you know but when it's a soft tissue
injury we don't see anything like that
or the muscle between our temples that
injury we
we we do not we do not uh as fans sit
here and say
anything but when the hell you coming
back you know yeah we don't we don't
treat brain health
as a society no we don't like it's like
toughen it up
kyrie but but but but it would be beyond
helpful certainly since we have
established that this is
writ large the general sports
population's view
of something like this about when you're
coming back you know
you know what do you mean two to four
weeks what the hell you know with what's
going on between your temples figure it
out
that in order to combat that he's got to
talk about it
if this is what's going on yeah no i
mean
he had he had our attention uh kinda
like you know the guy that you mentioned
that has five thousand followers with
fifty four thousand likes yes uh he has
everybody's attention
uh he always has everybody's attention
and uh if he were to
speak to somebody you know the media uh
post something on instagram something i
think he could do a lot of uh
a lot of good to to bring to the
forefront his reasoning for stepping
aside remember this is a guy who did not
want to play in the bubble
because he thought it would distract
from uh
the racial justice conversation and
social justice conversation that was
being had
at a higher level than that than ever uh
you know back in the summer
so uh having said all that and it'd be
nice to be
a minimum communicator steve nash and
his teammates in the organization and
sean marx
having said all that um if he shows up i
actually think they're gonna over
correct
because it maybe this is wishful
thinking
they've heard uh the jokes they've seen
the memes they've seen the 2k
simulations they've seen all the stuff
about them fighting over
they'll take the last shot i think it
may at the early stages
they might be too unselfish because it's
not like harden
is not a gifted passer in facilitator
you know we
he has been he can be what he wants to
be kyrie irving
can facilitate and we know the offense
certainly can run through
kevin durant and get everybody involved
they like each other enough
uh and i think they want this to work
enough to i think at the beginning the
issue is not going to be who's taking
the last shot or
who's taking the most shot it might be
actually overpassing and being too
unselfish
the question for me is just really how
they're going to handle it when things
get tough because inevitably
super teams always run into some kind of
adversity some kind of trouble
and that's when you see what they're
really made of inside i would pay a
member of the media on the
kyrie's first zoom if he does in fact
have it to say to him now that you've
got hardened
uh how does he compare with durant or
lebron in terms of the people you've
played with who can make a last shot
what about the controller
[Laughter]
i would pay i would i would put a
question on everybody's mind so yeah
do you know what i mean i would pass i
need to know this and how many
and or how many coaches do you have now
that's another you really want to kind
of
right unpack things and and if you are
playing so well
um should uh should michael holly and
michael smith's fantasy basketball team
that's dfl in the rich eisen show league
uh should should you be acquired by them
how about that as a question
is that a good question or a bad
question wait a second
oh my god wait a minute
franchise mode dfl frank michael i hate
to tell you wait a minute yeah
so i see i got to talk to my guy
in uh my assistant he was supposed to be
on top of that
it's funny michael because i throw him
that's okay because holly threw you
under the bus when i hit him on the same
exact subject last week at this very
at this very time but did he fix it
though no no you're still laughing just
yeah just keep keep doing what you guys
are doing because you don't keep keeping
tj out of the basement
through me under the bus i mean he just
it like did he did he make any kind of
moves or whatever i mean i
i just like i'm i'm a hands-off kind of
owner
i'm a hands-off kind of owner i i i hire
good people
i let them make decisions delegate you
delegate michael and here's the thing
and i know you've got to go
so do we too i don't want meanest to
stir up dissension before the
latest episode of brother from another
but uh have a good show
yeah this might come up appreciate you
take care you got it that's michael
smith
he and michael holly nba experts don't
let the fantasy stuff
uh undercut them hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here